it's it's a privilege to stand here
as your Shadow Chancellor
under Kia stalma's leadership
but I know what a responsibility this is
too
we are facing a national emergency
prices up
the cost of the weekly food shop up
people's wages not keeping up
on Friday the chancellor had an
opportunity to set out a serious
response to the cost of living crisis
and he failed
what did we get instead
a tax cut for the wealthiest one percent
increased Bankers bonuses
and more than 50 billion pounds piled
onto the national debt every single year
they didn't just break their own fiscal
rules for the tenth time in 12 years
in one go they borrowed more than in any
single budget since 1972.
with inflation already high and interest
rates are already Rising
the message from financial markets was
clear on Friday
and this morning
that message is even more Stark
Sterling is down
that means higher prices as the costs of
imports rise
the cost of government borrowing is up
that means more taxpayers money will go
into paying the interest on our
government debt
and in turn that means the cost of
borrowing for working people will now go
up to
with higher mortgage repayments for
families
and all for what
not to invest in the industries of the
future
not for our NHS and not for our schools
but for tax cuts for the wealthiest a
return to trickle-down economics an idea
that has been tried has been tested and
has failed
thank you
why should my constituents in Leeds West
why should people in merseyside pay for
tax cuts for those who are already the
wealthiest
it's not what anyone voted for it's
putting our economy in danger and
Conference labor will fight at every
step of the way
conference
let me tell you what I believe
I believe that hard work should be met
with their reward
I believe that strong public services
are the backbone of any decent Society
I believe that inequality divides and
holds us back as a country
conference I believe that the task of
building a fairer Society is a moral
responsibility and more than that it is
the route to a stronger economy
the truth is at the heart of Labor's
plans for growth and today I want to
tell you why
last April
on a Cold Spring evening I knocked on
the door of a constituent
when I reached out to shake her hands
it was purple
and freezing cold
already back then she was afraid to put
the heating on
struggling to get by on the small
pension that she had built up through a
lifetime of work
as energy bills and inflation rise even
higher
I often think of her
conference that is the Stark reality
facing people all around our country
today
and while the Prime Minister spent
months denying the need for action on
Energy prices labor was calling for a
freeze on the energy price cap labor was
calling for an end to the indefensible
premium paid by families with prepayment
meters
and crucially labor was calling for a
windfall tax on the unimaginable profit
being made by the oil and gas companies
because the proper windfall tax would
mean that working people didn't have to
foot the bill
[Applause]
prime minister
it's content to let energy Giants pocket
the cash and leave your children
and your grandchildren to pick up the
tab
under these stories those with the
broadest shoulders
carry the lightest load
and not by accident
but by choice
conference it is time for a government
that is on your side and that government
is a labor government
the effects of Putin's War have
reverberated around the world
and we will not waver in our support for
Ukraine
of this crisis are global
our unique exposure to Rising Energy
prices
is a result of the choices of
conservative governments
in action on insulating homes in action
on renewable and nuclear energy and the
sheer irresponsibility of closing our
gas storage facilities
we are feeling the consequences of a
12-year Tory experiment in unilateral
energy disarmament
and what's their answer
lifting the ban on fracking
conference
fracking is dangerous it is bad for the
planet it won't even reduce our bills
and with labor it will not happen
here is our alternative
our green Prosperity plan
to provide the only sustainable solution
to the energy crisis
to free ourselves from dependence on
Russia to invest in solar in wind in
Tidal in hydrogen and in nuclear power
and to pass on to our children a fairer
and a Greener country
this is a moral responsibility
and it's an economic necessity
on climate change the costs of inaction
today will mean far greater costs
tomorrow
I refuse to leave our children to pick
up the pieces of our failure
conference I will be a responsible
Chancellor I will be Britain's first
green Chancellor
Ed Miller Band has just set out how the
next Labor government will cut to energy
bills for good
by generating all of our electricity
from clean sources by 2030.
but our green Prosperity plan is about
something else too
it is about economic growth
because British businesses are falling
behind in the global race for new
Industries
and that matters
it matters that the largest offshore
wind farm in Scotland has its blades
made not in Scotland but thousands of
miles away
it matters that the rest of Europe is
powering ahead with electric battery
factories and we are stuck in the slow
lane
it matters that Germany France and the
US are making the running with green
hydrogen but we are not
we have the ability
but we want the jobs here we want the
factories here and we want British
businesses to take the lead
yeah here is the deal
the next Labor governments will create a
national wealth fund
so that when we invest in new Industries
in partnership with business
the British people will own a share of
that wealth
and the taxpayer will get a return on
that investment
wealth flowing from jobs in electric
battery factories in the West Midlands
the Northeast the Northwest and the
Southwest
offshore wind driving investment in our
ports from the Humber to Southampton
East Anglia to Belfast
clean steel with jobs in Rotherham
Sheffield scunthorpe Cardiff and Port
Talbots
and carbon capture in our Industrial
heartlands in grangemouth and in South
Wales in Humber and in Seaside and here
in merseyside too
because conference when I say I want to
buy make and sell more in Britain I mean
it
what you will see in your town in your
city with labor
is a site that we have not seen often
enough in our country
cranes going up
shovels in the grounds the sounds and
the sights of the future arriving
secure skilled jobs for plumbers
electricians and joiners for designers
scientists and engineers
wealth that will flow back into your
community and onto your High Street
wealth that the British people will own
a stake in wealth that is invested in
our country's future that is a real plan
for climate that is a real plan for
growth and Conference that is a real
plan for leveling up
foreign
carbon economy made right here made in
Britain it is time for a government that
is on your side and that government is a
labor government
but the Tories
six different plans for growth in 12
years each announced with great fanfare
each making no difference a library of
failure
conference they've had 12 years
have they got growth up no have they got
inflation down no have they got child
poverty down no have they got the NHS
waiting lists down no and have they even
got the debts and the deficit down no
conference it's 12 years of failure
and now
they have replaced leveling up
with trickle down
an economic philosophy inadequate to a
modern world and a moral philosophy
inadequate to a decent Society
trickle-down economics is a very simple
idea
if we just slashed taxes and regulation
we will unleash investment and growth
that how wealth is shared doesn't really
matter
false gaps between people and places no
importance workers rights consumer
protection strong Public Services all
worth sacrificing
wealth is just created by a few people a
few businesses
it's why at the same time that ministers
lecture low-paid workers about showing
restraints that they can't restrain
themselves from removing the cap on
Bankers bonuses
I dare any Tory MP to tell a nurse or a
care worker to their face that what our
country needs right now is bigger
bonuses for bankers
true trickle down is a very simple idea
and a very wrong one
not just wrong because it isn't fair Run
2 conference because it doesn't work
trickle-down is wrong because how wealth
is shared does matter to growth
High inequality strangles the spending
power of working people
it piles its social costs onto our
Public Services
suffocates potential
trickle-down is wrong because in a
turbulent World businesses need
government as a partner
trickle down is wrong because strong
institutions and robust public finances
provide the foundations for a strong
economy
and trickle-down is wrong conference
because a strong economy needs strong
Public Services we will defeat the
failed ideas of the past with the focus
the ambition and the ideas for the
future
conference
here's the truth
wealth doesn't trickle from the top down
it comes from the bottom up and the
middle out from the talent and the
efforts of tens of millions of ordinary
people and from thousands of businesses
our economy needs the most productive
most high-tech businesses to thrive in
Britain
and we all rely on what I call the
everyday economy
on transport workers and delivery
drivers on supermarkets and Retail
workers are NHS and care workers
don't let anyone tell you that they are
not wealth creators too
they
they are key to our security as a
society
and yet too many of them are amongst the
most insecure
overworked
underpaid
undervalued
the Tories that trickle down ideology
has nothing to offer them Beyond longer
hours lower pay and less respect
earlier this year I met a family in
Worthing
a Mum and Dad working five jobs between
them struggling to make ends meet
constantly juggling work and child care
as a family they only got half a day a
week together they felt that any hope of
buying their own home had evaporated
good people working hard
do you know what the mum said to me
she said
you just wonder if you're doing
something wrong
conference something is profoundly wrong
and let's be clear Liz Truss
we've not fallen behind our neighbors on
growth on productivity or on pay
because British workers lack graft
it's not working people that are the
problem conference is this government
that is the problem
thank you
I'll tell you what a growing economy
needs Rising wages so that money flows
back into vibrant High streets parents
with the time to thrive at work and
spend time with their children families
with enough savings to weather a storm
and people feeling the confidence to
take risks to change career to learn new
skills or start a business
so
with labor
there'll be no bonfire of workers rights
as the Tories intend
as Angela Rayner announced
we will introduce a new deal for working
people with strengthened rights fit for
the times we are in
and that's not all
on day one as Chancellor
I will write to the local pay commission
with a simple instruction
that the minimum wage will be set at a
level that reflects the Real Cost of
Living
conference
the last Labor governments delivered
Britain's first ever national minimum
wage the next Labor government will
introduce a genuine living wage
that's how we will give working people
security and that's how we will grow our
economy too
it's time for a government that is on
your side and that government is a labor
government
foreign
about growing a 21st century economy
it's no longer enough if it ever was for
government to Simply get out of the way
the challenges of global instability of
pandana pandemics wars and climate
crisis
demand that government work in
partnership with business
if I were Chancellor right now I would
bring together a National Economic
Council that will bring together
industry and trade unions so working
people and businesses were at the heart
of economic decision making
I have been privileged in this job
to visit businesses across our country
from Rolls-Royce in Derby pioneering
Research into carbon neutral Aviation
to Oxford nanopore leading work on DNA
and RNA sequencing
right through to local businesses like
Castleton Mill once a key part of West
yorkshire's textiles industry and now a
collaborative space for Freelancers
remote workers and startups
the world is changing fast
but the British capacity
for Enterprise for Innovation and for
hard work remains undimmed
when I talk to business they don't tell
me that their number one priority is
corporation tax
they tell me about the need for properly
targeted investment allowances the need
for workers equipped with the right
skills
the need for certainty and a sense of
direction from government
and yes the need for a sensible working
relationship with our European Neighbors
so we will take those issues heads on
starting with the biggest tax problem
facing British businesses
our unfair outdated system of business
rates punishes High Street businesses to
the advantage of online Giants
so labor will level the playing field
we will abolish business rates and
replace them with a fairer system fit
for the 21st century
that new system that new system will
mean that businesses will get
revaluation discounts straight away
rather than waiting for years for their
money back
and here's more
today Jonathan Reynolds launched our
modern industrial strategy that
recognizes the importance of businesses
at the high-tech Frontier and of our
everyday economy
it sets out a mission to make our
economy more secure
we will use all powers at government
disposal to buy make and sell more here
in Britain
we will make Britain the best place to
start and grow a business Guided by the
work of our startup review headed by
Lord Jim O'Neill
and we will give our Nations and regions
Mayors and local leaders right across
Britain the tools to shape their own
future
in labor-run Wales under Mark Drakeford
in our city regions and all around the
country we are seeing the difference
that labor can make in power and Steve
Rotherham thank you for the leadership
that you show here in merseyside
and Conference
if you're remotely serious about growth
then you've got to make brexit work
our Agriculture and our food Industries
rely on trade right across Europe but we
have a deal that doesn't even include a
Veterinary agreement
we are pioneers in Creative Industries
but we have a deal which light ties them
in knots over visas
we are the second largest exporter of
services in the world but we have a deal
that doesn't include the mutual
recognition of professional
qualifications
so we will fix the holes in the
government's Patchwork brexit deal and
instead of picking needless fights with
our largest trading partner we will work
together with our neighbors and our
allies in our national interest
Labor's approach proudly pro-worker and
proudly pro-business supporting
Innovation sharing opportunity Reviving
our high streets conference it is time
for a government that is on your side
and that government is a labor
government
I am proud to have started my career as
an economist at the bank of England
it's operational Independence is an
enduring contribution by the last Labor
government to Britain's Financial
stability
growth and social justice must be built
on firm foundations
yet this government
has undermined the bank's Independence
sacked the respected permanent secretary
to the treasury and gagged the office
for Budget responsibility
the chancellor and prime minister
meanwhile resembled two desperate
gamblers in a casino chasing a losing
run
but here's the thing
they're not gambling with their money
they're gambling with yours
they've lost credibility they're losing
confidence they're out of control
thank you
and I've said this before conference but
be in no doubt
there can be no return to austerity
it has left our country poorer
our Public Services as breaking points
and our public finances in tatters
I make this promise to you
labor will not waver in our commitment
to fiscal responsibility
that is why I set out the fiscal rules
for the next Labor government a year ago
every policy that labor announces
and every line in our Manifesto
will be carefully costed and fully
funded
last year I told this conference that I
was more than happy to take on the
Tories when it came to economic
competence because I know we can win
I'm now wondering whether they even plan
to show up for the fights it's
it's becoming clearer by the day labor
is the party of economic responsibility
and the party of social justice
conference it's time for a government
that is on your side and that government
is a labor government
thank you
now
we need a growing economy we need a
growing economy to pay for modern
sustainable Public Services
but a growing economy needs strong
Public Services too
this is personal to me
my mum and dad were Primary School
teachers
I'm really proud of that
my sister Ellie and I used to play for
hours in my dad's classroom while he
worked late into the evening
because he wanted the kids that he
taught to have the very best start in
life
this was all in the face of conservative
governments
hostile to the very idea of Public
Service
I went to school under those governments
I remember what it was like
this is why I joined this party
and it is why I am here today
strong public services are the
foundation
of a strong Society
and Conference
we owe everything to those who work in
our National Health Service
[Applause]
today is on its knees
it is a social priority and it is an
economic priority
in the last three years half a million
people have left the labor market
more than half of those due to long-term
illness
so as Kia stama set out a year ago we
will guarantee access to mental health
treatment within a month to anyone who
needs it
here's more
we need strong sustainable public
finances alongside strong sustainable
Public Services
so our priority
is not tax cuts for the wealthiest few
it is securing our public finances
and investing in our Public Services
conference
I can tell you
with a labor government those at the top
will pay their fair share
the 45p top rate of income tax is coming
back
cheers and here's what we'll do with
that money
the next Labor government will double
the number of District nurses qualifying
every year
we will train more than 5 000 new health
visitors
we will create an additional 10 000
nursing and midwife places every year
more than that we will implement the
biggest expansion of medical school
places in British history
so I believe the number of medical
students so our NHS has adopters that it
needs
it will fall to us
to fix the damage that the Tories have
done
we have done it before and Conference we
will do it again
know that these are Labor's priorities
strong public services to support people
and grow our economy
A Greener fairer Britain with jobs for
people in Britain Industries owned by
the people of Britain profits shared
with the people of Britain pro-business
and pro-worker for a stronger economy
where you do well
because when you do well Britain does
well
hope and opportunity whoever you are
wherever you live that is Labor's vision
for Britain that is what we are fighting
for let me tell you it's time for a
government that is on your side that
government is a labor government and be
in no doubt conference that government
is on its way
okay